good afternoon everybody today i want to
begin with the good news the approval of
the oxford astrozenica vaccine which is
a fantastic
achievement for british science which
will allow us to vaccinate more people
and also vaccinate them
more quickly and there's one important
development
that's helping us to accelerate our
vaccination program
across the whole of the uk we've had new
advice from the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization that the
first
dose can protect people against the
worst effects
of this virus because the benefits kick
in
after two or three weeks and so
from now on we will give a first dose
to as many vulnerable people as possible
with the
second dose to follow 12 weeks later
and what that means is we can vaccinate
and
protect many more people in the coming
weeks
i know that everyone watching this will
want to know when
when you when can get your vaccine
and all i want to say is that we are
working as hard and
as fast as we can to get the supplies to
you as soon as we have the supplies
we'll be getting them uh into people's
arms
to summarize where we are we have to
face the fact that we've got
two big things happening at once
in our fight against kovid ones working
for us and one
working against us on the plus side
we've got two valid vaccines and we're
racing as i say
uh to get them out on the on the
downside there is
a new strain of the virus which is
spreading much faster and surging
across the country and we've seen a 40
increase in cases in england
in the last week alone almost 15 more
patients in
hospital more than at the peak of the
first wave and yesterday
uh sadly we recorded almost a thousand
deaths
across the uk for the first time since
april
so at this critical moment with the
prospect of freedom within reach we've
got to redouble our efforts to
contain the virus and that's why the
health secretary has announced that
more areas of england will be moving
into tier four
from tomorrow and i say again
no one regrets these measures more
bitterly
than i do but we must take
firm action now and that's why
we have to think very hard about schools
because
today of course it remains the case that
keeping children in education is a
national priority and it remains the
case
that schools are safe
but we must face the reality that the
sheer
pace of the spread of
this new variant requires us now
to take even tougher action in
some areas and that does affect schools
and let me set out for you
what this means in most of england
primary schools will still reassemble
next week
as planned for the new for the new term
but in the areas we've just published
today on gov dot
uk i'm afraid the start of the new term
will be delayed
until at least january the 18th when
the latest data on those infection
rates will be reviewed and that is
because
the rate of transmission in these areas
is so high and there's just such
pressure
on the local nhs that extra action
is required to control the spread of the
virus
the children of key workers or those who
are considered to be vulnerable will
still
uh go back to primary schools from next
week
wherever they live in england and they
are not affected by today's announcement
in secondary schools all vulnerable
children and the children of critical
workers
will go back next week across england as
originally
planned but we will ask exam year pupils
in secondary schools to learn remotely
during the first week of term and return
to the classroom
from 11th of january the remaining
secondary school pupils ie non-exam
groups
will go back a week later that is from
the 18th of january
but i i want to stress that depending on
the spread of the disease
it may be necessary to take further
action
in those in their cases as well
in as i say the worst affected areas
to minimize disruption in schools and to
fight the disease we're massively
expanding our testing operation ensuring
that every secondary school pupil is
tested
as they return and regularly thereafter
i again want to thank teachers pupils
parents who've worked so hard to keep
schools safe
and keep them open
we're also asking universities to reduce
the number of students who return
to campus in january prioritizing
medical courses
and others requiring face-to-face
teaching
and in all cases students should be
offered
two rapid tests when they return
all of these measures are in the end
designed to save
lives and to protect the nhs
and for that very reason i must
ask you to follow the rules uh where you
live
tomorrow night and see in the new year
safely
at home that means not meeting up with
friends or family
indoors unless they're in the same
household or support bubble
and avoiding large gatherings of any
kind
we are still in the tunnel of this
pandemic
the light however is not merely visible
uh thanks to an extraordinary feat of
british engineering if you like the
the tunnel has been shortened or we're
moving
faster uh through it and
uh that gives uh me great confidence
about
the the future in the spring so for now
let's redouble our efforts let's follow
the rules
protect our nhs and together
make 2021 a year in which we leave this
tunnel
behind us